certainly we've seen that there has been
this shift of scapegoating towards the
trans Community but even more broadly
than that do you think that some of the
progress that has been made culturally
not legally but culturally when it comes
to equality and respect and LGBT rights
do you think we've lost a little bit of
it not a little bit a loss and we have
become the targets and when I say we I
mean all gay trans people well you know
the whole alphabet of it all of us
together right and if we don't stand
together while they attack the most
vulnerable of our people
one percent of the population and less
than one percent is trans
and those are the people that they're
going after it's very dangerous it's
very depressing and it's a a very
nazi-esque tactic and it should terrify
everyone